-Welcome back.
I'm talking to Dwayne Johnson,
whose new NBC series,
"Young Rock,"
premieres February 16th,
at 8:00 p.m.
And joining us right now --
I'm very lucky --
is one of the actors from
the series, Bradley Constant.
Bradley, there you are.
Thank you so much
for coming on, bud.
You play young Rock.
You play Dwayne Johnson
at 15 years old.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Do you know --
I mean, you must have heard
some of the stories.
But I know from some of the
stories I've heard from Dwayne,
15, he's lived
a pretty crazy life.
I mean, he was getting arrested.
I mean, he's constantly
moving around.
I mean, crazy stories that you
don't -- you have no idea.
-Yeah.
-Dwayne, you remember
there was that one --
kids thought you were
an undercover cop?
-Yes. When we were evicted
from Hawaii,
we were forced
to live, or go to, Nashville.
So, when I went to Nashville --
In the state of Hawaii,
you can get your license at 14,
or at least you could back then,
when I was a kid.
And so I show up in Nashville,
driving a car,
full, full moustache,
6'4", 220 pounds.
The kids were in --
You know, I looked
not like too many people running
around Nashville at that time.
So, "21 Jump Street"
was a popular TV show
that was happening at that time.
Oh, for sure, they were like...
-You're a narc.
-..."This is the real life --
We have the real-life
'21 Jump Street' happening
in our school right now."
And Bradley has the opportunity,
and he crushed it,
of playing me at 15,
that undercover-cop time.
-Bradley, are -- are you -- were
you ready to take on that role?
-Man, I was -- I was pumped.
I was extremely excited, yeah.
-Dwayne, we have a photo of you
at 15 years old.
What do you remember
about this guy?
-Oh, God.
Don't do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! That's 15?
-That's 15.
And I'm clearly aggressive.
And I loved boom boxes.
And, you know,
that was at the time
where I was getting in trouble,
trying to stay
on the right path.
And, you know, Bradley,
as you can see now,
has just such
a great personality.
And he's so funny and charming,
and he's a tremendous actor.
Even though our show
is a comedy, you know,
he's got to step into
those 15-year-old shoes
where I was a complicated kid
who was getting
in trouble a lot.
But -- But also --
And this is what I shared
with Bradley is, man,
I was getting in trouble,
I was getting arrested, I was --
We got evicted,
I was angry that we got evicted,
I was angry that we were living
paycheck to paycheck.
And I said, "But, Bradley,"
I said,
"If you can find
that little voice
and little thing inside you
that allows you still
to be a good kid."
And I said, "You know,
because I was still
a good kid at that time.
I think he really,
really crushed it.
-Here's a photo of me
at 15 or 14.
That's me.
[ Both laugh ]
-Is that is a mullet?
Is that is a mullet?
-Yeah, it was --
-It is a mullet! Wait a second.
-It's kind of being a mullet
a little bit.
It's a lot going on.
I don't know what
hairstyle that is.
-And look how happy you are.
Wait a second.
Are you --
Is this karaoke time?
-This is my house.
We had --
My dad fixed some jukebox
someone was throwing out.
I was doing -- either singing or
doing stand-up or something.
And it looks like there's a
pizza-delivery guy at the house.
I don't know why --
who that man is
with the red shirt
and white pants.
[ Laughter ]
But odd.
Anyway, that was a Friday night
at the Fallon house.
I was probably
doing something ridiculous.
But I was --
Oh, that's me --
All right, we can stop
with the photos now.
This is just --
-Wait, wait, are you going --
Are you going to school?
[ Laughter ]
-That is not
a Halloween costume.
That is actually
what I wore to work.
I got a job --
I got a job as soon as I could.
I can't believe
they had that photo.
Gosh.
-What were you doing?
Were you at a pizza joint?
-[ Laughs ]
-I was an old -- looks like
I was an old-timey bartender.
I don't know what I was doing.
That was a --
-Ice-cream parlor or something.
-No, I was a bag boy
at a grocery store.
I was the best.
Uh, yeah.
If you --
People would request --
They would request me.
They're like, "Get me Jimmy."
I was fast,
and I would put eggs on top.
I knew how to do it, man.
-That was my first --
one of my first jobs, too.
I worked at a grocery store.
-Did you really?
-Up until last year,
when I booked this, yeah.
-Bradley, where's your
15-year-old photo?
-Oh, goodness.
-Didn't we drag one
out of Bradley's --
Yeah, ooh!
-[ Laughs ]
-What's this guy?
What's this bit?
-All right.
Look. Okay.
So, 15-year-old Bradley.
I was --
I think I was trying to say,
"Hey, I don't have money,
so don't ask me,"
so I had empty pockets
and everything.
I was like, "Don't bother me."
I don't know.
-Wait.
That's your bit is to come in
with your pockets hanging out?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
I felt really cool
with that sweater, man.
Bamm-Bamm with a
Louisville slugger, come on.
-Let me see that.
That's not even, like,
the real --
Bamm-Bamm had white hair
or blond hair.
-Look.
-Yeah, that's like Blam-Blam.
-That's like Boom-Boom.
[ Laughter ]
-Boom-Boom.
-That's fake Bamm-Bamm.
Oh, my gosh.
Bradley, when you
come on my show,
'cause I'm telling you
right now, dude,
when you come on my show,
'cause I'm telling you,
I think you're gonna be
nominated for an Emmy one day,
and when you do,
you come on my show,
and you have to have
the pockets out
and the Bamm-Bamm sweatshirt.
[ Laughter ]
-I got it.
Don't ask me for money
'cause I won't have it.
[ Laughter ]
-Congrats on everything.
I want to show a clip
of the show.
Here's a look at the premiere
episode of "Young Rock."
Take a look at this, everybody.
-Anyway, best part is, Karen
invited me to a party tonight.
So, life is good, huh?
-It is.
-Well, it's not gonna last.
Fine-ass Karen aside,
the reason why these girls
haven't been giving you
the time of day
isn't 'cause you look poor.
It's 'cause you look like
an undercover cop,
like Johnny Depp
from "21 Jump Street."
-No one thinks that.
-Dwayne, everyone thinks that.
-[ Whispering ]
He's looking at me.
He's a cop, like Johnny Depp.
-I'm 15!
-You have a full moustache,
and you're bigger than a dad.
You look like you work
at an auto-parts store.
-Whatever, man.
None of that matters
now that I got a girl into me.
-Yeah, but that girl thinks
you're rich, and you're not.
-Dwayne Johnson
and Bradley Constant.
"Young Rock" premiere
February 16th
at 8:00 p.m., on NBC.
Daniel Kaluuya joins us
when we come back.
Thanks so much, guys.
I appreciate it.